hey guys how's it going it's Justine
welcome back to another fun unboxing
today I'm going to be checking out the
DJI Osmo camera and this is a 4k steady
camera which is pretty awesome because
it's not that expensive so most
steadicams are crazy set up and they're
hard to use well this is a pretty simple
handheld device that connects to your
smartphone so let's check it out I saw
it in person at CES and I came home and
I had to have it I've been looking at it
since it came out not too long ago but I
thought I don't need it and then I saw
it and I thought nope still don't need
it but do I want it and do I want to
show it to you guys and do I want to use
it to make awesome videos yes I do let's
unbox it and hopefully you guys will
think it's awesome as well did I really
need a knife to cut that little piece of
plastic yeah I did I'm sure I'm gonna be
using this to chase my dog around the
house definitely something that needs to
be shot in 4k I am so excited I've been
wanting this for a little while
trying to just pull it out okay maybe
that's not what seats for Oh a nice
little carrying case oh this is great in
case you forget what it is and here we
have directions disclaimers whatever
[Music]
it's like a nice neck strap fancy don't
know what this is
I can resort to this Lister tells me
what's in it this is a protection cap
charging cable wrist strap very
important battery charger very important
not important and the battery look big
battery I'm s guys like my new unboxing
table could you tell it's a little
different it's a standing desk it's
actually dining-room table
who's counting I like that it's got
little slots right here I can just set
my things in now what we've been waiting
for it said it came with an SD card did
I accidentally throw that so is it
already in here SD card is already in it
if you're looking at it it's on the left
side we've got our back tray which goes
in here there's an arrow that shows you
how to put it in so you just put the
flat side pointing towards the front
okay let's hope that this has a little
bit of battery life so we can use it
looks like I'm gonna have to try two
battery first so I'll be right back
in the time that this has been charging
I've been doing a little research online
and I've watched some videos and the
biggest complaint with this is the audio
quality because the microphone is built
into the camera and there's a bunch of
motors that are running while this
device is actually trying to stabilize
your video so that is one of the
problems but I looked up a few
workarounds and I order the necessary
pieces to attach a microphone mounts on
here so as soon as those pieces come in
I will do an updated video and show you
how that worked so let's turn it on
things are happening here's where you
can attach your smart phone I've already
downloaded the app and it's called the
DJI Go app which is pretty much the same
one that you use for your drones with my
phone in here on stretch it to fit now
let's try to turn off my phone I don't
want to turn it off hey my device is
activating camera is starting so if you
guys are familiar at all with DJI and
their drones this is basically the same
sort of setup and the same sort of app
so it's now calibrating itself and it's
giving me a quick tutorial so here's
what you guys look like
so there's my office there's a camera
exposure what else can we do here looks
like the white balance is a little off
selfie recenter if you click this three
times it'll automatically turn around
and you can get a selfie shot it's
pretty cool I'm into it let's go find
the dog let's find the dog let's find
the Douglas find the dog dog hello dog
okay but I can't play with you because
I'm filming I'm making a video I'm
making a video
dog I'm making a video mm-hmm who's the
cutest dog of all me Eddie
okay just a little motion hey come here
come here
[Music]
um okay hi I'm back this is really fun
I'm gonna have so much fun with this and
I'm really excited to kind of get this
all set up especially with a little
microphones there's one that I can
attach the back here it also has an
audio input so you're able to add
external audio which will be so
fantastic because as you guys can hear
now there's a fan that's running so
that's definitely something that's going
to be picked up in the onboard audio so
that's it
this is the Osmo I'll put a link in the
description where you guys can get this
on Amazon and to look for some more fun
videos coming soon
where I'll go outside give this a real
test and see what I think after I
actually use it for a little while also
be sure to look out for the audio rig
updates out you're putting that video
out hopefully soon as I get everything
in to make this work that's it I think
it's pretty cool so far I'll give you
guys another update as I play with it
more alright see you later bye yes to
call me on my cell phone late night when
you need my boy we're playing pool and
ankle it's heat we're marketing you see
ever and would you mind starting all of
your questions by saying like I just say
it like an American invading a foreign
country oh yeah I going to murder all of
you